two roads a few houses
this is Sutherland in the kirua
semi-desert a five-hour drive from Cape
Town guest houses here are named after
planets or galaxies and mock-up
telescopes signal to any visitor that
this is the place to be in South Africa
for stargazers up on the hill is the
most important astronomical observatory
on the African continent the telescope
facility of the country's National
Research Foundation here nature and
high-tech live in peaceful coexistence
the Springboks are mainly drawn to the
compound by the grass that grows all
around it astronomers come for the
hardware to be specific for the South
African Large Telescope or salt
it's the largest single telescope in the
southern hemisphere financed by several
different countries including Germany
this eye on the sky was completed in
2005 made up of ninety-one hexagonal
segments its enormous mirror is 11
metres wide and 10 long the segments
have to be aligned correctly to one
millionth of a millimeter to bring
images clearly into focus
so things you can do with a really large
telescope because you can look at very
faint things or you can look at price of
things but on very short timescales and
so it's interesting to study things that
vary on timescales of of minutes and
seconds and we can actually do that with
all of our instruments have that
capability to do high-speed work
researchers here can observe how compact
star remnants absorb gas from companion
stars for instance until they have so
much mass that they explode as
supernovas or watch as black holes suck
in endless amounts of stellar dust the
astronomers want to investigate the
universe more thoroughly this
spectrograph from the United States will
soon get an armed with new measuring
devices they will allow it to collect
data about thermal radiation from space
and can observe regions hidden behind
dust clouds
the instruments have to be mounted on
this black beam it's a complex device
that follows the movements of the sky
the new instruments will allow the
astronomers to look deeper into the
universe in even more detail and they'll
be able to see the tiny movements of
stars that's the first step towards
detecting small rocky planets that orbit
far away Suns and they're of particular
interest because they could be home to
alien life David Gill banks team of
researchers use salt to investigate how
galaxies develop that's a central
question in modern astronomy they're
observing what are known as mergers
galaxies that look as if they're fusing
together the spectrographs breakup the
light of these celestial objects into
the colors that make up its spectrum
what we do with the spectra is we
measure how fast they're moving which
tells us what distance they're moving at
and then that tells us if the relative
velocity between them if there's a small
difference in speed between them that
means that they're likely to merge
together and if there's a large distance
between them they're not going to merge
together so we know that they're not
true mergers and spectroscopy is the
only way to tell us the images recorded
by salt and other big telescopes both on
the ground and in space are being
compiled into the astronomical virtual
observatory it's a huge library that
researchers all over the world can use
gleaning new knowledge from the trove of
data to uncover the mysteries of the
universe
you